and there are big news to discuss before  we even  get into the games  daniel dubov has tested positive for the  coronavirus and therefore cannot  continue the tournament  loses  by four feet to richard rapper today we  can see richard rapper joins  magnus carlsen in the lead in the  standings with with his default win and  it also means that daniel will not show  up for his last strong game against the  world champion  magnus carlsen  first of all of course we wish daniel  a speedy recovery and then peter  swiddler  there are a bunch of questions  that we need answers to first  should magnus carlsen stay in vike and  wait for daniel's recovery so they can  play round 13 later  second that would be best yes  is it unfair to anish geary that magnus  carson picks up a free point when  they're fighting for tournament victory  that is horribly